[Music]
I will do what I can don't take this the
wrong way Hans but we're not exactly
rooting for you you charmed your way
into Ana's heart and left it to freeze
when she needed you the most and if that
wasn't bad enough you went after Elsa
and tried to take over arendelle now
that's just cold so what's this we hear
about you popping up in frozen to last
we heard you were shoveling manure on
the Southern Isles where you belong you
better not be planning your revenge Hans
we're officially on to you
Hans is a villain if we've ever seen one
but there's a strong chance that he will
redeem himself in frozen to keep
watching to find out how Hans will go
from villain to hero she left me in
charge and I will not hesitate to
protect arendelle from treason just when
we thought that Anna was done with Hans
for good he comes creeping back into her
life in the most surprising way no one
expected Hans to be in frozen to after
all he was thrown into a jail cell and
shipped back to the Southern Isles at
the end of frozen so why is he slated to
make a comeback in frozen 2 we were sure
he'd never show his face again after
Anna gave him a knuckle sandwich but we
were wrong
Hans is officially listed as a character
in the sequel and honza's voice actor
Santino Fontana is reprising his role
oddly enough
Hans wasn't present in any of the frozen
2 trailers and he didn't make an
appearance at the d23 Expo however actor
Jonathan Groff who voices Kristoff tag
Santino in a cast picture on Instagram
Disney might be trying to keep Honda's
involvement a secret but it looks like
the cat is out of the bag and believe it
or not but some fans swear that Hans
does make an appearance in the trailer
but more on that later for now let's
find out what Hunt has been up to ever
since Anna and him at his own game six
years may have passed since we first met
Elsa and Donna
but according to Disney frozen 2 is set
three years after the first movie in
frozen fever we find out that Hans has
been keeping busy by shoveling manure on
the Southern Isles so it's safe to
assume that Hans has had plenty of time
to think about what he's done but his
thinking process can go one of two ways
Hans could have been planning his
revenge ever since we last saw him or he
could have used
time to think about the awful crimes he
committed and maybe just maybe Honda's
feeling guilt and regret there's no way
of knowing if Hans will be a good guy or
a bad guy and do to make us think he's
changed if Hans tries to betray the
queen and princess of arendelle once
again shoveling manure will be the least
of his worries but if he tries to help
Elsa and Anna they might pardon him once
and for all so now that we know what
Hans has to lose and gain let's find out
how he fits into the plot of frozen -
but you you were so desperate for love
you were willing to marry me just like
that Hans was nowhere to be seen in the
trailers but that doesn't mean that he
wasn't there in the first trailer we see
on a Kristoff and Elsa walking through
the enchanted land all of the sudden
Anna turns around grabs Kristoff sward
and swings it with all her might so what
if Anna heard a sound turned around and
saw Hans walking behind them since Anna
wouldn't hurt a fly unless that fly's
name was Hans we think it's pretty
likely that anna is swinging at her
ex-fiance but what on earth is Hans
doing in the enchanted lands we have a
few theories it's possible that Hans ran
away from home he was tired of being on
stable duty and kids say we really blame
him Hans might cross paths with our
heroes while attempting to flee but
since the enchanted lands are creepy and
unpredictable Hans might decide that
there's strength in numbers
you guys think that Elsa Anna and
Kristoff would let Hans tag along or
would they send him packing another
option is that Hans is on a path of
redemption please I can't
he might have heard that Elsa and honor
our journey in North to save arendelle
from a possible threat and he might have
realized that helping them is the only
way to redeem himself if Hans sacrifices
himself to save Elsa or Anna the sisters
would find a way to forgive him to
whether or not he's got redemption on
the brain remains to be seen some fans
think that Hans will be up to no good
and frozen - and honestly we wouldn't
put it past him
now that Elsa and honour are far away
from home it would be the perfect time
for Hans to try and take over arendelle
but
we hunt we'd like to see you try you
just be keeping Elsa's throne warm until
she gets home Hans was the villain of
frozen but he just might be the hero of
frozen two fans have been asking about
else's love interest and whether or not
she'll find love come the sequel there
have been rumors about Elsa fallen in
love with a girl or someone like Jack
Frost but according to some other
superfans else is destined to wind up
with Hans there's a theory that Hans
will still else's heart at the end of
the sequel and become the king of
arendelle what do you guys think well
Hans become a hero and fall in love with
Elsa or will he prove everyone right and
remain at Disney villain sound off in
the comments
give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited for frozen too and don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching we'll catch you later
[Music]